on se merci de nous rejoindre alors que
le nombre de faits à caractère
antisémite a fortement augmenté en 2018
selon le ministère de l'intérieur
emmanuel macron est en visite en israël
il rappelle défendre son combat de
chaque jour entre ce fléau comment
expliquer cette recrudescence comment
lutter surtout contre elle de quels
moyens disposent en nous c'est l'objet
de notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
noémie alioua journaliste yves 24 news
hauteur de la sphère sarah halimi aux
éditions du cerf 2018
à ses côtés charles rojzman essayiste
auteur de violence dans la république un
l'urgence d'une réconciliation paris la
découverte 2015 bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être là d'avoir accepté de jouer
le jeu du débat alors tout d'abord avant
de commencer à discuter christophe quel
salaire 1 qui a annoncé en février
dernier une forte augmentation des actes
antisémites +74 % entre 2017 et 2018 les
explications en images
[Musique]
où
monde
tous
[Musique]
on a les chiffres qui font froid dans le
dos charles roseman comment vous
expliquer cette recrudescence des actes
antisémites en france et le fait que peu
de juifs
aujourd'hui ce sont en sécurité sur le
territoire français je crois qu'on a une
fausse idée d'antisémitisme on voit
alors sémitisme à partir de ce qui s'est
passé par la deuxième guerre mondiale la
shoah hitler le nazisme et on ne voit
pas que l'antisémite c'est quelqu'un qui
ne se voit pas qui ne se perçoit pas
comme quelqu'un de mauvais mais
quelqu'un qui réagit à la malfaisance
des juifs
ça a été le cas depuis depuis toujours
dans l'histoire et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui par rapport à l'état
d'israël qui est un peu le gil des
nations et où l'on ou l'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui ses mutés et c'est la
malfaisance de l'état d'israël qui est à
l'origine de l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui
qui est parti d'un antisémitisme
musulman à partir de la naissance de
l'état d'israël qui a eu du mal à
accepter cette existence d'un état
souverain juifs intérieur d'un
territoire entièrement musulman et c'est
ensuite transférés dans des milieux des
milieux je dirais de gauche en europe à
la fois chrétien qui voit le dans le
dans le le palestinien et le les
personnes du tiers monde en général
comme des pauvres face à un monde plus
riches
quel monde occidental est également
l'état d'israël et même là la réussite
de l'état israël a augmenté même cet
antisémitisme par rapport à cette
question de de la dynamique entre
pauvres et riches et puis le côté je
dirais ce qui restait du marxisme qui
est le la
la dynamique entre dominants et dominés
et où on voit des
lieux qui sont d'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui d'extrême droite pour des
raisons diverses qui ont qui ont accepté
cette ce transfert de l'antisémitisme
qui au départ était surtout d'origine
islamiste
oui mais elle est là pour ça qu'on parle
de nouvel antisémitisme mais si vous
voulez le l'intimité on a toujours
existé la seule différence c'est
qu'aujourd'hui prend une nouvelle forme
lee prend la forme de l'antisionisme
aujourd'hui on va pas dire sale juif on
va dire ça le sioniste qui voulait c'est
juste une façon vis-à-vis de la loi de
se protéger c'est un argument mais je
crois que l'antisémitisme finalement
leur dynamisme n'est qu'une nouvelle
forme de l'antisémitisme mais sait-on si
ces meetings si vous voulez aurait pu
trouver un autre argument si je puis
dire
et quand on parle de nouvel
antisémitisme ce qu'on veut dire par là
c'est pas qu'il est nouveau puisqu'il a
été théorisée déjà depuis vingt ans
notamment par l'historien georges
bensoussan on dit nouvel antisémitisme
parce que justement ce n'est plus
l'antisémitisme chrétien qui s'appuyait
sur l'argument du déficit c'est à dire
les juifs ont assassiné jésus c'était un
argument qui avait été utilisé pendant
des millénaires pour justifier
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui les
principaux antisémites se servent des de
sourates du coran et se servent de
l'argument d'israël pour condamner les
juifs et c'est pas uniquement des
condamnations alors il ya des chiffres
bien sûr qu'ils sont on voit une
explosion des chiffres de
l'antisémitisme mais au-delà des
chiffres c'est des histoires c'est des
enfants qui sont massacrés en allant à
l'école c'est des gens qui se font
assassiner et c'est vrai que toutes ces
réalités l'a finalement c'est
l'antisémitisme d'aujourd'hui et c'est
la question de l'insécurité beaucoup
plus largement parce que la question
antisémite il ça me semble très
important l'an de la question dans steam
it is ne pourra pas de toute façon pas
de régler tout seul il faut un plan
beaucoup plus globale et c'est pour ça
que le destin des juifs est intimement
liée en tout cas en france au destin de
la nation
sharon il ya une pression que j'aimerais
apporter vous parlez tous les deux de
l'état d'israël mais est ce que ce n'est
pas plutôt parfois la politique tout
simplement du gouvernement israélien en
local
mannequin depuis un petit moment bien
sûr bien sûr écrit par la recrudescence
avait quand même récente il ya eu ce que
certains dénoncent et appelle que
c'était pas votre cas mais en tout cas
une forme de colonisation
certains en tout cas des noms mais je me
fais l'avocat de l'intéressée
intéressant parce qu'ils font avec les
pas des solutions et on perd ça les gens
devant leur télé serait bien sûr mais je
ne sais pas ça le projet politique du
gouvernement israélien est constamment
critiqué et critiquable sont les
premiers sont les israéliens si vous
voulez il ya une démocratie extrêmement
forte en israël avec des partis
politiques qui s'oppose de façon très
dure avec un camp anti natanyahou
extrêmement puissant j'ai participé avec
24 nous à de nombreuses manifestations
d'anti natanyahou d'anti bibi comme ils
s'appellent il ya une démocratie très
fort le la critique de natanyahou est
extrêmement puissante elle existe en
israël comme à l'extérieur elle est
possible et plus que ça j'ai envie de
vous dire n'importe qui encore euro a le
droit de critiquer natanyahou où la
politique de l'état hébreu où la
colonisation si vous voulez appeler
comme ça où tout autre chose qui est
rattachée à israël mais le problème si
vous laissez que cet antisémitisme n'a
rien à voir avec une à une argumentation
construite intelligente sur laquelle on
peut débattre sur la politique de l'état
d'israël ça n'a rien à voir c'est à
masquer la preuve c'est que c'est
irrationnel
la plupart du temps les gens qui qui qui
prennent l'argument d'israël pour
critiquer les juifs ne ne sont ne sont
pas rationnels si vous voulez c'est là
toute la tyrie l'antisionisme couvert
d'antisionisme et là il ya quelque chose
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il ya une
différence entre critiquer une politique
et la diabolisation
il ya une diabolisation d'israël sur les
mêmes thèmes qui a eu une diabolisation
des juifs
c'est à dire les juifs dans le moyen
haut moyen-âge tuer des enfants
innocents
les juifs de me voulait de la domination
du monde par l'argent et donc qui a la
même chose avec l'état d'israël
qu est ce qu une diabolisation une
diabolisation c'est quand d'abord on
exagère les méfaits
et qu'ils peuvent être réels les juifs
effectivement ont participé à des
mouvements bolchevique l'époque de
hitler c'était le grand thème de hitler
c'était les des exactions commises par
les bolcheviks d'un lien entre les
années 18 années 30 la même façon il ya
un capitalisme
il ya eu des banques juive et cetera
donc il ya des réalités mais le problème
la diabolisation
c'est que ces réalités d'une part sont
exagérées d'autre part font l'objet de
rumeurs et de mensonges et de propagande
et d'autre part elles sont je dirais on
ne regarde pas l'ensemble du contexte et
à dire arrêter des enfants par exemple
de 12 13 ans ça paraît quelque chose
d'ignoble mais on ne vois pas pour
quelle raison et on ne le dit pas pour
quelles raisons ces enfants ont été
arrêtés
par exemple on ne fait pas la différence
entre ce qui se passe en israël y
compris avec gaza et ce qui se passe en
syrie
le nombre de morts et de deux
palestiniens qui ont été tuées au liban
pointe et tu es en jordanie qui ont été
tuées en syrie est largement plus
important que les palestiniens tués en
par les israéliens
on ne fait pas par exemple la différence
entre un conflit qui a fait 70 mille
mots en ou cinquante mille morts je sais
pas exactement en 70 ans et des conflits
comme en syrie où on a quatre cent mille
morts entre le conflit entre l'iran et
l'irak 1 million au nord avec des
enfants tués dans toutes ces situations
là c'est ça la diabolisation
il ya quelque chose de très important
aussi qui me paraît très important s'est
il faut absolument dissocier aussi
toutes ces questions là parce que là on
est en train de faire une sorte d'
amalgame où justement on essentialise le
juif comme le sioniste comme l'israélien
on met tout ça dans un énorme sac en
pensant que c'est la même chose alors
que en france par exemple si on prend la
question française il ya toujours eu des
juifs français sioniste ou pas c'est
leur opinion mais en quoi les juifs
français devrait pays
et entre guillemets pour la politique de
netanyahu qu'est ce qui fait que eux
aujourd'hui on les traite de sale
sioniste alors que parfois parfois ils
n'ont jamais été en israël parfois c'est
pas l'heure question c'est pas leur
réalité si salée et 20 ils ont choisi
mais encore une fois ils n'ont pas à
payer les pots cassés et ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il se passe
quelque chose en israël les juifs
français payent et là le premier
argument c'est évidemment dans
l'histoire récente c'est le seconde
intifada c'est à dire que lorsqu'il y a
eu une histoire politique très compliqué
en israël c'est bien il a eu une
explosion des actes antisémites et on a
envie de vous dire mais qu'est ce qu'ils
ont à voir là dedans
les juifs qui vivent en france et qui se
retrouvent agressé en bas de chez eux
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à voir avec moi ça
relève la réponse politique et notamment
celle de d'emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
encore lors de cette conférence de
presse à jérusalem aux côtés de benyamin
netanyahou le président qui a affirmé
que la négation de l'état d'israël était
de l'antisémitisme écouter
l'antisionisme lorsqu'il est la négation
de l'existence d'israël comme état est
antisémitisme 75 ans après la libération
des survivants d'auschwitz des citoyens
de france et d'ailleurs sont pris pour
cible parce qu'ils sont juifs
ce retour de la haine entre nos temps
présent a donc emmanuel lacroix est ce
qui prend la réponse du bon goût du bon
côté selon vous mon avis à emmanuel
macron a un grand talent pour essayer de
plaire à gauche à droite un peu partout
et je pense qu'il a aussi son son
rapport à israël
alors je ne suis pas dans le secret des
dieux et je ne connais pas le les
alliances les les demandes qui lui sont
faites au point de vue de géostratégie
mais je parle simplement de sa de la
peur de ce gouvernement de ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les banlieues
s'il prenait des positions uniquement
pro israélienne parce que je pense que
que il a déjà la réputation comme eux
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se dit donc
dans les banlieues françaises la
réputation d'être dans les mains des
sionistes comme on le dit justement très
très habituellement il a la réputation
d'avoir travaillé dans la banque
rothschild donc il ya tout un courant
c'est le seul président français à se
rendre dans les territoires palestiniens
lors de lever les gens qui sont celles
aux arrêts y aller je pense que nous
avons un gouvernement qui a très peur de
ce qu'ils pouvaient embrasé les
banlieues et donc il faut qu'ils
ménagent la chèvre et le chou mais cette
loi va dans le mauvais sens pour lui si
si je vous écoute parce que associer les
affaires ça va pas forcément déjà ont
des préjugés dont sont aujourd'hui mais
je pense que il en faisant ce qu'il a
fait aujourd'hui avec la police
israélienne en imitant chirac il a
essayé de donner d une caution à à une
critique de des israéliens aussi donc il
essaye de ils essayent de gouverner
comme ça au au mieux ou au pire en
essayant justement de de plaire à tout
le monde
sur cet épisode si ça reste
la communication politique à ces ratés
puisque c'est qu'une pâle copie de
l'original il a essayé de rejouer un
petit peu l'épisode chirac qui a marqué
d'ailleurs son quinquennat mais qui
aujourd'hui c'est une redite si vous
voulez qui est assez qui assez risible
d'abord parce qu'il essaie d'asseoir une
souveraineté sur un territoire alors
qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui en france il
est extrêmement contestée il ya les
gilets jaunes dans la rue demain tous
les samedis depuis des mois il ya les
liens des grévistes y aller il ya les
retraites ce volet il est une nuit même
extrêmement contestée sur son territoire
et il va en israël pour faire la leçon
morale c'est d'un point de vue politique
assez pitoyable d'un point de vue
communicationnel assez ridicule je pense
qu'il ne gagnera rien en est d'ailleurs
il fait preuve d'un manque d'originalité
à c'est assez catastrophique pour ce qui
est de ses de son discours sur la
question de l'antisémitisme moi je
trouve qu'il a un discours depuis son
quinquennat depuis le début de son
quinquennat assez assez ferme sur la
question je veux dire il se positionne
il a bien conscience qu'il ya un
problème le souvenir par exemple qu'il a
cités et là il a été quand même assez
assez courageux de citer le nom de sara
lee me lors des commémorations
d'anniversaire du vel d'hiv souviens
c'était encore une question très
compliquée à ce moment là il a fait le
choix d'en parler c'est une preuve de
courage je pense qu'il veut malgré tout
montré aux juifs de france que le
pouvoir les soutient que le pouvoir et
de leur côté qu'ils se soucient de leur
sécurité et de leur bien-être
en france malheureusement c'est comme et
encore une fois je c'est important de
voir toujours cette question là dans une
perspective beaucoup plus globale le
problème c'est que comme toujours les
paroles n'enchaîne pas des actes si vous
voulez c'est à dire qu' il ya des grands
discours
il y à des politiques on se souvient de
la fameuse phrase de manuel valls et
julie sans la france c'est pas la france
il y a des grands discours qui qui
montre la protection de l'état français
vis-à-vis de leurs concitoyens juifs
le problème c'est que dans les actes on
voit qu'il n'ya pas de répercussion
puisque les actes antisémites continue à
augmenter puisque malgré tout il ya un
sentiment qui se développent chez les
juifs d'insécurité et donc c'est le
problème de
de la parole politique si vous voulez
qu'il n'a plus de qui n'a plus vraiment
qui n'est plus efficace et ça c'est
beaucoup plus large
sincèrement c'est avec des lois comme ça
d'assimiler le sionisme antisionisme à
l'antisémitisme qu'on va régler la
question d'ailleurs je voulais vous
faire réagir
michèle sibony ancienne vice-présidente
de l'union juive française pour la paix
pour elle la loi maillard est une loi ou
qui démocratique et qui bafouent
l'égalité entre les citoyens français je
vous laisserai réagir après c'est une
très mauvaise décision de l'assemblée
nationale très antidémocratique très qui
vient en contre-pied du de l'article 1
de la constitution de la vème république
qui promeut l'égalité de tous les
citoyens entre eux c'est une résolution
dangereuse pour les juifs elle les met
en en leur donnent un statut très
particulier à l'essor du collectif
national au fond le racisme en france
existe il vise les juifs mais il vise
aussi les arabes ils visaient musulmans
et de ville et les noirs il vise les
roms il vise les asiatiques
il fallait prendre peut-être à
l'assemblée nationale la mesure du
racisme de ses ravages en france mais
mettre en exergue de cette manière là
l'antisémitisme pour des raisons à
l'évidence politique on y reviendra
me paraît ça fait de cette loi une des
lois qui seront qui resteront dans
l'histoire comme une loi scélérate une
réaction justement ça mais plutôt en
danger les juifs est ce que vous
partagez cet avis de michèle sibony
alors je pense qu'elle n'a pas lu déjà
le
le texte parce que ce n'est pas une loi
contraignante ce n'est pas une loi qui
aura une incidence sur le code pénal sur
le code civil c'est quand même important
de le rappeler parce que l'impression
que les gens prennent ça comme un acte
de censure
on sait que le justement la censure se
développent et finalement en allant
contre cette loi on a l'impression
d'aller contre la censure qui ce qui est
totalement faux
parce que c'est une loi symbolique donc
c'est une loi qui n'implique pas de
modification du code pénal et du code
civil c'est quand même important de le
préciser
oui mais elle parle bien de symboles ça
me met des juifs auraient en danger
parce que ça les enlève ça les extraits
du reste de la population française
comment est-ce que ça toi cette loi a
été décidée elle a été décidée après que
le philosophe alain finkielkraut a été
agressé par les gilet jaune
il a été agressé sur quelqu'un sur celle
d'un sur certains généraux absolument
certain gilet jaune
il a et légumes traités de sales
sioniste de merde je précise de salles
sioniste de merde d'accord donc ils
appellent traité de salses et traiter de
sale juge non comment est ce que la loi
peut répondre dans ces cas là c'est ça
la question
il ya un problème et un vide juridique
alors il n'a pas été comblé puisque
encore une fois s'il loi non
contraignante mais il y a un problème à
partir le mans on peut se cacher
derrière
si vous voulez des mots qui sont des
mots valises on sait très bien ce qu'ils
veulent dire charles rojzman bah moi je
pense d'abord qu'il faut voir d'où les
gens parlent la madame siboni fait
partie d'un groupement très violemment
anti sioniste et elle parle au nom de
cette extrême en solitaire cette
idéologie anti sioniste mais moi je
voulais dire autre chose quelque chose à
propos quelques autres choses à propos
de l'antisionisme antisémitisme
c'est le sait le fait que les gens
parlent d'un c'est le si vous voulez
l'antisionisme et l'antisémitisme est
surtout le fait des milieux non
populaire c'est-à-dire deux milieux qui
sont à moitié du quai qui lisent
des journaux qui lisent qui suivent des
réseaux sociaux et qui ne connaissent
pas véritablement l'histoire de ce
conflit
je m'en suis aperçu bien des fois qu'ils
ne connaissent pas le contexte dans
lequel ces choses-là se passe et qui
sont influencés par des idéologies comme
je le disais tout à l'heure des
idéologies anti néo anticolonialiste des
idéologies quelquefois clairement
antisémite de chrétiens par exemple je
crois que c'est quelqu'un parlait de
vertus chrétiennes qui sont devenues
folles c'est à dire de milieux que de
chrétiens de gauche
oui c'est ça chesterton et de milieux
néo marxiste de milieux qui ont la
nostalgie d'un prolétariat qui n'existe
pas et qui l'ont transféré sur les
musulmans et donc on l'a quand même dans
dans dans toute cette histoire
on a beaucoup d biologie et le derby
problème est davantage question oui
c'est pas d'éducation est d'ailleurs
assez inquiétant un français sur des
hauts cantons ne connaît pas l'histoire
de la shoah ça augmente chez les jeunes
20%
les jeunes qui connaissent pas vraiment
cette les histoires de création mondiale
sondage ifop publié en 2018 un français
un sur dix qui n'a jamais entendu parler
de la choix d'ailleurs jean-michel
blanquer a affirmé qu'il s'attaquerait à
ce sujet ce que c'est pas là le vrai
problème quand je cours je ne pense pas
que ce soit un problème d'éducation je
pense est un problème de casser ces
milieux tous ces milieux qui qui vivent
uniquement avec une seule propagande
en ce qui concerne les enquêtes moi je
ne prends pas personnellement que ce
sixième des français n'a pas entendu
parler de la shoah à son âge il je
l'aimé glisse lui je sais pas moi je
crois qu'il a la volonté
de dire qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est
que la shoah parce que derrière eric et
apparemment de l'enseigné dans certains
quartiers c'est ce que notre sol et le
ministre de l'éducation
absolument et c'est pour ça que moi qui
travaille dans plusieurs pays étrangers
à réconcilier des gens qui sont des
ennemis des adversaires qui ont dû faire
face à des guerres civiles
je crois qu'on devrait aider les gens à
sortir de leur milieu à se rencontrer
plutôt que les éduquer leur expliquer
comme d'autres formes cd d'éduquer les
gens à l'antiracisme avec sos raciste
alors que ce n'est pas vers et racisme
on voit bien que ça a servi à rien je
pense qu'il faut plutôt que les gens
qu'on aide les gens à sortir dans un
milieu ils y apprennent c'est un peu le
travail que je fais moi à être en
conflit à se parler mais en face aux
négociations ça serait bien de terminer
effectivement sur ce point position
stylisation substitut elle conflictuelle
c'est à dire allez allez tous se mettre
sur la table ou dans un processus où les
gens petit à petit ce pour en confiance
et se disent réellement ce qu'il pense
et partagent leurs informations
et je dirais ensemble deviennent un peu
plus intelligent un peu plus raisonnable
à noémie aliot il ya plusieurs choses
mais il arrive qu'il m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est le livre de l'historien georges
bensoussan qui s'appelle
l'instrumentalisation de la shoah et qui
explique très bien que finalement
parfois on fait trop on pense que
l'histoire va se répéter de la même
façon or l'histoire ne se répète jamais
de la même façon donc je ne crois pas
moi quand un enseignant la shoah tous
les jours aux enfants ils seront moins
antisémite
au contraire c'est justement parce que
c'est une nouvelle histoire qu'il faut
la voir avec des nouveaux yeux et ce ne
sera pas suffisant
bien sûr que c'est une très bonne mesure
et ce sera pas suffisant et on ne
luttera pas contre l'antisémitisme en
enseignant davantage la choix je ne
crois pas au contraire c'est plutôt
l'esprit critique qui a besoin d'être
enseignée mais pour revenir peut-être
sur ce que sur ce que vous disiez
je suis assez d'accord en fait vous êtes
en train de critiquer en gros le modèle
communautariste c'est à dire que le vrai
problème c'est justement quand on parle
en france quand manuel valls part parlé
d' apartheid en tout cas nos deux
quartiers ghettoïsés c'est ça le grand
danger et quand vous dites que les gens
qui se mélangent plus c'est ça le grand
danger encore une fois ça c'est une
question les mélanger charles grossman
puisque vous avez écrit un livre sur le
sujet les solutions justement pour
mélanger les perdants ni a priori il
faut mettre ensemble des gens qui ont
dans des villes dans des dents des dans
différents endroits du pays qui ont des
problèmes à traiter des problèmes
douloureux pas forcément des militants
une cause ou d'une autre mais des gens
je crois que le modèle pour moi ça a été
le démarrage des gilets jaunes c'est à
dire la prise de parole de citoyens
avant que ce mouvement soit récupéré
comme on sait comme il l'a été mais
vraiment une
une prise de parole de gens qui savent
des choses qui ont besoin de les
partager qui ont besoin d'être écoutés
et souvent c'est parce que les gens je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
dit noémie à loyat je crois que les gens
vivent dans un milieu et non que la
propagande de leur milieu et ne sortent
jamais de ce milieu le problème c'est
que c'est un mot c'est une parole qui
est complètement cessé un mot qui
parfois ne veut plus rien dire mais si
on le prend à son sens le plus strict la
vraie solution c'est la république c'est
à dire c'est un modèle républicain avec
du bien commun avec des particularismes
qui restent à la maison tirage chez soi
et on essaie crée du commun au delà des
différences c'est la solution le
problème c'est que le mot république
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on ne
veut plus rien dire
mais avec ce qui est le propre de la
démocratie qui est le conflit parce que
le conflit sans violence c'est le propre
de la vie démocratique et il ya plus de
conflits comme il ya plus de conflit
chacun reste chez soi et se développent
une image fantasmée des autres
moi je vois bien que par exemple même
dans des parle de l'antisémitisme mais
moi je sais qu'il ya des milieux dans
lequel on dit pis que pendre des
français on dit quand on est quand on
est soi même de nationalité française
ont dit mais les français qui par
exemple certains milieux musulmans vont
dire les français qui ne sont pas
musulmans sont vont aller en enfer
effectivement on va bien sûr tous les
formes de racisme de ce soir en tout cas
c'est le mot de la fin merci à vous
noémie hawa et cheikh osman d'avoir été
avec moi on dirait que tu rt français